citizens of the reject Nation Happy New
Year to you I don't know when this is
going to air this is our first reaction
of the new year we are diving into deep
blue sea I have not seen this John I'm
ready to have a whale of a Time Coy you
know I walked in here and we were
talking about how we haven't seen this
and the only thing I know about it JN
didn't even know about it that there is
a song the extent I know about this is
there is a lyric deepest bluest my head
is like a shark fin okay what that means
I don't yet know but L Cool J said it
and ladies love cool James so we're
going to find out and speaking of who's
your favorite rapper turned actor
thespian leave it in the comments people
now please do like this video so we know
that you enjoyed it and that your head
is like a sharks fin please do comment
on this video that your head is like a
sharks fin and please do hit that
notification Bell as well as subscribing
so that we may continue to make these
videos for you dear sharkfin viewers
also if you want to check out this full
length watch along from beginning to end
feature length with our resting watching
faces head on over to patreon where
patrons get to experience all of this
Glory as well as exclusive videos that
Greg and John do over there and we want
to thank the fine folks at prepper for
prepping Us by making this video prep
tastic edited they do a great job
helping us out over at prepper so much
much appreciated without further Ado
it's time to finally discover what ll's
been saying all these years let's deep
let's blue let's
[Music]
see
oh
yes for boing helicopter
shot
so for boing already oo almost Zack
Efron it's like Zack Efron and Ken
Marino
kenron
oh is that shark vision I hope ll's the
shark yes you man he's the best rapper
turn actor if anybody could do it he can
that's
real did you feel something yeah I feel
the Riz on this
man having ay man man this does look
like a way to party the
2000s I often say we're having a party
man when I have a party that's how you
know the party started are we having a
party we're we are we're having a party
we're having a
party oh no don't feed the shark why
grape blood in the water I don't know if
that works the same I don't know if
that's going to summon much shark's
gonna have a
headache oh not the
teddy and the stereo no longer a
party more
[Laughter]
wine
oh it's going to the deep blue sea yeah
I hope the teddy bear becomes the
protagonist it's paddington's origin
story yeah dark wo
oh good thing they were in their
swimsuits
prepared ah shark
fin hey you got to have good shark music
too got a lot to live up to True bars
High
Jaws oh the butt right in the bo oh butt
got saved oh Harpoon man is that Tom J
Thomas Jan's here Thomas J know we'd get
Tom
Jan versus King shark yes his vegan
Powers have activated it's milk and eggs
oh I'm so excited not today na
blonde Thomas Jane yeah from the opening
scene of the
Punisher
expectations Thomas J CH skyrocketing
expectations oh always oh it's La based
EXC
I know that was Fargo Building yeah
yeah oh oh she mean business focus
determination a test
shark what we're attempting to achieve
here has never been done we're this
close to the reactivation of a human
brain cell 200 million I've sunk in this
company but when the Market opens Monday
I don't like heights especially fallen
from I don't blame you I'm sorry honest
mother after the events of Jurassic Park
yeah decided to get into the shark
business not taking any more chances
tell me Mr have you ever known anyone
with Alzheimer no by the end all my
father could do was ask why my mother
wasn't she did and each time I told him
she was dead I had to watch him take
that loss like a car wreck 200,000 men
and women develop Alzheimer's each year
what if you could end all that suffering
with a single with a single
shark how does the shark relate give me
till Monday morning 48 hours I'll give
you results Skyrocket your stock price
or I'll help you pack the got brass
gumption I respect good gumption and a
good Dutch angle I don't know why they
came him that that shot his hand on his
shoulder and all that is very
Regal that's true their dle was very
strange like you posing for a painting
right
now quite an impressive spee you G back
there now they're going to Jurassic Park
perfect ela's new blur here we come the
thing in the Himalayas Al we were just
trying to do something together having
fun things went bad but you saved all
those people not all no drama mysterious
backstory
yeah this also has that like late 9s
gritty like Amber pinkish color palette
yeah just film stock makes me happy true
that seeing a movie shot Navy built it
for World War II submarine loading NE
moth B it we picked it up added aquatic
depends your dime I guess looks like
Alcatraz floats it does look like
Alcatraz float big shell Metal
Gear look at that handsome blonde Tom
Jane ah how many big animals is this guy
taking
on what do you think Amigo she's a
12-footer she's beautiful she wants to
give you a big kiss I bet got a damn
license
PL pollution
sucks that's either a real shark are a
very good animatronic yeah I think it's
real I almost wouldn't be surprised if
this was some of f houses like we did
you know yeah well cuz after Jaws it's a
challenge you want to out Jaws jaws and
you want it to work and you want it to
you know Bruce to exist
Jin biologist Welcome to our Island
Paradise where's
Tattoo
planee B the
BL we don't get TV we don't watch movies
and alcat so how much do you know about
our facil treat me like a tourist no I
hate tourists and I've decided I'm going
to like you what an interesting eyeline
he is given that he's like the corporate
Overlord
guy man
shark
oh nah it's got to fight him yeah jump
in ah he's Chris Pratt and that's
blue they're
buds
woo
damn yeah R the shark let's
go best way to
travel what a great
shot my man
King orm saved the day all right what
state's it
from Louisiana I'm thinking he's bought
in a pet shop bat R ate everything in
his fish tank then he ate the guy that
bought
him we need to
talk
later let me just take one last look at
you Russell Franklin President of the
board of chimera pharmaceutical oh
that's a good name Chimera always goes
well yep that was incredible actually
they don't like the taste of us very
much I mean how could anyone resist look
at that BOD Man that's true high protein
man they bite you because they think
you're fat little seal or Rich suit oh
that's what you get for caring about me
a minute ago friendly place you got full
sentences usually he just kind of nods
that means he loves you word travels
fair about why you're here and
all he's dressed like people think rich
people dressed like yes he is
whoever costume design this movie is
like what's a rich person got the
sweater it's on luck and a polo jacket
yeah why
not beneath its glassy surface a world
of gliding mon
bars that is a very cool POV
shark hey Ben I'm picking up a nasty
little of a Squall about 30 mil
out oh uh he's got to be trapped yeah
where are they going they hate me too
they're going home we run a skeleton
crew on the weekend literally yeah
foreshadowing Dr Jim Whitlock the most
brilliant man ever taking a leak he's
pissing into the wind how brilliant can
he be you'll see actually he's just
marking his territory so the Sharks stay
out of it mhm they don't go over there
now they used to what happened deedi you
missed with the first shot took two hits
to even slow it down what are you
kidding me two of these killed it I
forgot he was an actor Michael Rapaport
is alive look I already told the doc I
lock the pen like I do every other night
fish got out some other way huh what are
you looking at me like that for uh-oh
who are you going to trust me that's who
he only trusts sharks because I'm
trustworthy someone wrote that down that
is dialogue he said it hey how high are
these fences off the water well given
the surface variations and tensil
strength got short answer man English
please an English please 8 ft give or
take a c c a centimeter do water change
is a centimeter yep I'm sorry I'm making
Aquatica sound like some kind of mental
hospital no no Aquatica yes truth is it
is but almost everyone here is top of
their game is this haunted room actually
stretching I do immediately think of
House on Haunted Hill Vibe this time
yeah there are three sub levels Su level
one is living quarters two wet lab and
workshops and three engineering an air
locked wet entry wet entry let's
go we are mature enough to handle we can
handle some
jokes go to the wet lab
next
oh oh floppy oh Zip drive that was a zip
drive that was like the mega floppy of
your yeah you could save so much many
images yes cuz I think a floppy could
only hold like three and a half full
size bit Maps I got two words for you
sugar zip disc had car to do it as soon
as you called from the city oh my God be
ready by tomorrow night Scar Guard baby
Scar Guard preliminary trials no choice
we wait your whole life for single
moment zydrate comes in a little glass
file so what exactly does a Shark
wrangler do pretty much what it sounds
like I guess yeah hey an aam Mas did
some wreck diving in one of these off
the coast of
Spain God yeah the sweater the collar
the glasses so much a rich man would
wear this you um like wck div and I bet
you're really good at it we're on in the
water old cat and mouse thing don't
float puns you're the man right yeah
yeah I'm the man he means that both ways
well a man's always got a file what to
say 2 years 11 worth smug me how'd you
make your money man you the first rich
guy in history squeaky
clean look I got a workable deal here I
don't make waves I meet the terms of My
Parole I'm not out to change a world
like the doc and I'm not out to wreck it
either I feel like Thomas Jane's the
writer Samuel Jackson's the
director and that's how the tone of this
movie Yes is coming
together and the cast director and
costume designer are drunk right now yep
there he is let's go oh my God LL cake
CHF
beautiful work you got a big fat
butt
bless you try my last nerve Don't Make
Me Drown Your feathery
ass it would only be better if he had an
LL blue jay
ah or scrub jay whatever any kind of J
some
J oh eating time oh foreshadowing I'm so
exced excited there's a chef L Cool J in
this movie I'm going
in you guys
hungry is water wet every line he says
I'm just like he's trustworthy Michael
rap report he's worthy of
trust
oh they're traveling in hers
yes oh oh what are you doing super
shark shark Supremacy Dr mallister we
have a situation up here could you
please come to surface level Dr you come
to surface level please all these people
are going to die how it starts except
for her she's too pretty to die yeah
she's trying to do good work for the
wild
yeah a that was a great shot though with
her like tiny silhouette I do like the
concept cuz like sharks haven't had to
evolve so they're so perfect I wonder if
there is any brain studies being used
with shark brains could be El so perfect
work% he's microchipped a lot of
sharks May
Day no
no happy
birthday flare guns we worked so hard on
the surprise that we even had to fool
the audience into thinking this was some
kind of setpiece
yes how's life underwater lot less
complicated than it is on the surface I
impli that he such good
puns nice work with that new tiger shark
today one day you'll have to tell me how
you learned was a tiger shark one day
he'll take me up beer maybe I will it's
will work for me Carter but like you
said one day they are Cris Pratt and
business lady using a hormonal enhancer
we increase this female's for brain to
five times normal size to harvest more
protein well protein that may reactivate
that will that will reactivate human
brain cells is stored in the full brain
of the shark I'm just amazed that we've
come so far so fast without genetic T
genetic engineering to increase brain
masses in direct violation of the
Harvard genetics compact not to mention
Chimera policy oh hey we're in
international
waters they're hunting in packs they'll
only eat other sharks you're reading too
much into it that gen one ATT a 25t boat
am I reading too much into that too is
my ADR
okay did you tell Franklin I'm just a
fish keeper lady for bringing in that
shark ahead of schedule was a very bad
idea do you like your job sharks don't
care about jobs are you threatening me
Doc no but if we don't pull off that
test tomorrow we're all on the street
make a nautical punt about that Street
Sharks see you did you should be in the
movie I'm ready I dialogue for days you
guys dialogue raise those fences like I
asked care that's not a yes definitely
not a yes no within a
[Laughter]
centimeter oh storms are Brewing oh
water's about to rise shark's about to
escape
uhoh damn Heavy Artillery man I'm going
to go kill that
storm he's going to punish it typhoon
meat Harpoon welcome to my power Mr
Franklin Tony Hawk skate shark shot it's
the best level in Tony Hawk Pro Skater
one I see so many places to grind yeah
collect the
skate check pen monitors and lagon
monitors I can't imagine as much
visibility below Carter you copy it's
about to be the perfect stor oh Bingo
Elvis has left the building okay we
picked you up but visibility is near
zero no problem what do you want from
Theory
alone nice nice way to create a
suspenseful
hallway it's like a slasher
movie visibility is pretty great
actually going to say that's at least
got to be like
75% I don't know 80 zero maybe more how
loose are we being with the rounding we
can see you very clearly
who oh them
teeth how long have they been
synchronized lately
this they're getting
smarter tell me I didn't see that you
didn't see that they recognized that gun
sharks did not swim back withs the cans
It reversed he saw it those sharks are
taking out the cameras the sharks taking
out the cameras no God human
brain
oh pretty easy code to
remember the shark already knows it yeah
Carter do you
copy negative over it's just out there
free ball in the whole ocean the Deep
come on
Bluey
yeah decoy very smart
oh look at him look how cool he is he's
got
her big big big fish the effects are
pretty solid across the board there's
got to be you know various CGS switching
to puppets a couple moments you could
see that it wasn't but overall I've been
impressed Shark Boy and Lava Girl United
at last
in God's creation oh not his ours least
he didn't say mine you know that's evil
scientist of him giv the credit words to
J is online transferring Exotics to
remote terminals vital science terminal
one I love that Michael rap report is
science Exposition guy yeah man he he's
holding it down for the every man he can
be an expert too 8 fet give or take a
centimeter yep heart rate 50 BPM with
Norms them gills she's sleeping like a
baby
okay now extract your brain jelly get
all that juicy
zydrate nope nope nope nope nope get on
out of
there owie in
position
it's a big needle I like it I like it
even though it's a prosthetic shark I
don't like any of this no thanks no
thanks oh they're going to show a
closeup yes they got do it oh the sound
design the
gusion oh yeah extract the brain juice
that
grease
now I'm the smartest
this a he respects her and her work
introducing two cc's of the protein
complex inter cultured inactive brain
neurons of an Alzheimer's patient
oh and what you're looking for here is
lightning in a bottle very easy to
identify putting complexes inter acting
with the
neurons whoa you woke it up neurons are
becoming hyper oh no is that good is
that good I think it's good membrane
Integrity improving it's getting smarter
improving is
good connection lightning still
firing I'll be there no sir for
6.56 seconds you saw what it's like not
to be
down whoever wrote this movie is a hero
she just had the best time
no no he's the first one the smoking AR
you asking for it oh no
wow get that shark out of there get out
of there rip your shackles out of the
ground
r no don't shoot the shark she needs he
knows that
gun oh oh
but now it's got a taste for human flesh
yeah and it's going to bring it back to
his friends it's going to tell him all
about how delicious that guy
wasam now
research we
Havey
iation his shirt looks like
DNA oh the needles the needles in this
movie this say worst than
satu
station a shark is going to snatch you
out of the sky man gu shark's going to
jump or something just keep doing what
you
doing oh it's not great up
here yeah
damn that looks like a practical set
looks like a real storm could be
Miniatures or something in part maybe
yeah oo it's all right Aquaman you got
this now does scars guard make it out
and he's the only one that
survives what a great
[Music]
irony get him out of there come
on so close ah but he's the bait it's
going to be like a fishing hook yeah
yeah he's the worm just wiggling on the
Stream
this movie has good storm chaos yeah I
feel the
tension damn it damn
it oh no scars
[Music]
guard no this would never happen to the
scars guard of today
no oh here we go oh boy
into the brain with
you might go the other way and might
pull the chopper out I don't know to
we're in a wet lab got a
visual it's okay keep trying gang woo
W just hit it a couple
times wow
who Damn It Fun
lady she barely got to fun oh no so much
is happening the sharks have caused many
explosions
yeah I love if this this helicopter
explosion took everybody out why did we
step nap stored in this Tower no what a
horrible spot for a fireworks
Factory oh my what was the this building
made of yeah was it an oil taker on the
side you know they just had a can of
gasoline a drum everywhere on every
single do so many explosions
doorway Brenda are you there this thing
is dead she was in the Napal
Tower we're about to see it the shark
tell me what that
is that's a good doctor oh you're
right whoa he's still alive what he's
just driving him around he's driving him
around oh he threw him he threw the
doctor sending a message you're marked
we're coming for
[Music]
you oh no guys be anywhere else but
there guys the wet lab is about to get a
whole lot
wetter
no
now the sharks are inside the house God
what a day on set this must have
[Music]
been
W good luck pushing that thing closed
yeah all that
pressure tension to this movie is solid
yeah you're writer versus director
assessment spot on cuz the director is
like I feel the the like
okay y here we are we got to get top
find some help
what there's no other stairway from this
level there's no way up get the
drill oh
no oh this water don't kill him yet need
a couple more minutes to bond with him
first I need to know why his head is
like a shark
fin all right all right all right okay
okay this lesson about the drinking
let's just say I've
learned praise the lord we go back past
the wet lab to the maintenance ladder we
climb down to level three we get to the
wet entry we take the sub top side two
at a time we go down to get up into
their domain
mhm no trust the bird that's your canary
bird what's the point of having a bird
if you don't listen to it yeah don't
just go straight into the mine come
on oh wonder who could have predicted
that maybe a
bird that's your first mate you should
have listened oh that's a big bottle too
this is the Lord saying no I want you to
drink more got to learn that lesson
LL
who
oh it's like an Indiana Jones like
Temple trap thing yeah don't get hit one
of those bullet wall things bullet jet
[Music]
darts it's like a ticking bomb every
room it's like like a fun adventure like
yeah well and it is kind of fun that
that you do almost have this slasher
quality of like like you're looking at
the corner and then all of a sudden it's
just water but it's still scary yeah the
villain of the movie is water as much as
it is sharks
yeah
excellent oh Through the flames shark
doesn't care about
Fire come on
bird bird you didn't name the bird love
that L's in his own movie like he's just
like thought you would get him to be a
part of The Ensemble but this is cool
I swear of all of all the actor rappers
turned actors L Cool J might be the best
one well Smith's pretty good that's
different Co listen respect to summer
time but that's different hey J wi it
change the game he's the first rapper
win a Grammy he paved the way that's
fair that's fair I take it back you're
welcome will I got you back and these
sharks they aren't just breaking down do
for the joy of it AR they after
us just what the hell did you do to
those shots made them Wicked smart that
brains weren't large enough to harvest
sufficient amounts of the protein
complex so we violated the Harvard
compound I made them bigger Gemini use
Gene therapist to increase their brain
mass larger brain means more protein as
a side effect the Sharks got smarter
this is an anti-gmo movie you stupid
I'm a stupid with this
research we could practically wipe out
degenerative brain disease think of the
generations that will be saved exactly
how many sticks of dynamite would you
have to set off in your ears before your
head that's a good one you don't see
what we've done here what you've done is
taking God's oldest killing machine and
given it will and desire what you've
done is knock us all the way to the
bottom of the goddamn food Chek dang
people will say Jim Brenda
us the 50 PBS of Napal from upstairs the
extreme close-ups are intense choice you
screwed with the sharks and now the
Sharks they're screwing with us instead
of a hammerhead it's a it's a screw head
shark hope one of them talks like the
Raptor in Jurassic Park 3
Alan Alan
Alan I do love that he's just got to act
things he's just him and bird hey you
know on your way
out keep you warm oh no not fair you
didn't even get to reunite with anyone
he didn't get to read the articles
that's what you get up for
no no no no no
no
no grab a pipe jump on a ceiling
pipe
go up go up oh this will be like the
cafeteria scene in yeah the door's going
to swing
[Music]
open oh no the Titan sub is wrecked no
how do we go down to get up can I have
to ride a shark yep
yeah that axe looks so tiny in his hands
I
[Music]
know oh there he comes oh
boy oh boy he's going to ram the
bookcase get under a box like metal gear
I am suddenly craving chicken noodle
soup oh bird bird you betrayed him
no oh no don't e bird little bird boat
your Fey
here oh
[Music]
bir
oh my God no
no
no grab that buoyant mustard bottle
it'll save you
yes oh get in the oven oh get in the
oven oh my
god
oh we could all
just and makes to the to sharks thought
of your plan before you did you're
getting Aqua dementia you could go first
to lead by example best friend thought
she was going to say something
different listen we put these on they
help fight hypothermia that's a start
we're going to have to swim out
of Sam
Jackson ah always got that gravitas oh
that is so scary yeah man that's a good
claustrophobic like it really is I don't
like it oh no damn it man now it's a Saw
movie What's going to light the
match I'm not Daniel any face the
lion you
are Against All Odds please make it
through this movie I be so EXC you got
this be the final girl L yes you've
earned it victory for a mere moment at
least
go it can back up we
learned oh
shazbot you blow up that shark you Ain
my
bird o Zam
Yes W that shark yes shark soup
[Music]
tonight the vibrations are too deep that
was from inside Raper pour has been
working out yeah just for this stand
next to Tom J I got in okay shape for
this you wouldn't get that close if I
were you what is murky might make it no
we
won't I'm a trustworthy guy I would know
the average human swims 2 ft per second
the average shark swims 50 ft per second
now what we have here is your basic
maintenance ladder this leads all the
way up to the surface I love you skogs I
really
do we don't know what kind of shape the
surface level is in we're better off
taking our chances with the sharks hey
you want to go swim with your little
fishes miss you go right in Miss I don't
work for you anymore okay I don't have
to keep your ERS oh you think water's
fast I have had it with these
sharks you should see ice it moves like
it has a mind like it knows it killed
the world once got a taste for her wow
wow who wrote this bottle when the
Avalanche came took us a week to climb
out we lost hope now I don't know
exactly turned on each other oh
seven of us survived the slide and only
five made it
out now we took an oath that I'm
breaking now swore that we said it was
the snow kill the other two whoa he
knows the taste of human flesh nature
can be lethal but it doesn't hold a
candle to man
[Music]
now you've seen how bad things can get
and how quick they can get that way well
they can get a whole lot worse so we're
not going to fight
anymore yes we're going to find a way to
get out of here this monolog first we're
going to seal out
this what
no things got
worse damn
W okay he's not he's not coming back
from that I did not see that happening
there I did not see that coming whoa
jeez man everyone gets to pece oh mid
monologue wow wow it was such a good
speech he just admitted to eating the
guy I think and then he got eight and
then he was going to talk about what he
did to that guy's son in the snow like
in faithful eight yeah next up what is
the precise structural failure limit for
Aquatica 3,200 tons what happens when we
get worn 3200 tons of water in this rig
floes or explodes floes the support
struts go first their tolerance is about
7 tons they're going to crack like
toothpicks then the walls are going to
buckle they can't handle more than 10
tons of pressure I want to be here for
that
man hug that toothpick I still can't
believe Sam Jackson got I scooped I know
woo it's not safe on dry
land oh oh get through the door go
go
go close the door
jeez oh my God yeah that looks so
painful the stunt team on this got
abused
yeah God everyone must have been just
like pruned out
24/7 oh
no oh no Thomas Jane St be fine I'm not
too stays behind he's dead yeah but uh
we're good
here oh now the fire they have to
contend with of course all the
elements whoa wow level one we can take
the stairs
out what a nightmare this is a great set
piece just water on one end elements
just a Perpetual explosion at the other
yeah like the story is Fun the dialogue
mostly doesn't work but when it does
it's exceptional like what an odd mix of
Parts yeah and the tension's great the
directing and the editing have made it
very like
taut shark vision
yeah ug they know where you are you
let's get the hell out of here that
shark is an wow the shark has a
point though the shark has been
experimented on they they did it to
themselves sharks break through that
door water's going to bring them right
to us now level two is only partially
flooded if I can get that access door
open the water will run off there by
some time oh my God you are a brave soul
muchacho a smart Tom
Jane man there there was a real Thomas
Jane Heyday back in the day really
was he still pops up in stuff but coming
right to
him I think he's about to sacrifice
himself no he can't I think the Thomas
Jane Heyday is about to end he can't
Don't force me into a Crossroads where I
have to decide whether I want Thomas
Jane to live or LL Cool J cuz I know I
can't have both I don't know where we're
at with it all knife and
open come on
buddy a shark is
rising oh my
goodness it's going to push him right to
the shark yeah
now he's going to ride the shark up the
the shaft oh my
dude go oh Jesus no
owie
ow oh that perspective be so ah now
they're tling them all I'm sorry no I
guess the requisite mousy good hearted
lady always dies yeah she lasted longer
than I expect yeah I don't want to die
grab my hand come on oh come
on God what a nightmare oh it's so
tense oh where is
it
oh damn it just handed her to him Dam oh
ouch oh what a horrible way to go that
is a mean shark that shark is pissed off
that is so malicious I bet this was
pitched as Jurassic Park for sharks it
feels like it I feel like jaws and
Jurassic Park were two desk notes
yeah sharks probably flooded that level
too nah that's
LL yeah you're right I think yeah my
man I lasted Sam Jackson we're on level
one we could take the access stair all
the way up to the surface the stairs are
flooded trust me I know are you sure
give us a goddamn break
kid not the move wrap apart he always
answers sometimes the answer you get
isn't the answer you
want who do I call get me God save us
emergency hatch on this level right this
level has build pumps on it for storm
runal if we could reot the emergency
generators we could drain one whole
stairway you build rat who are you going
to trust that's right he trust me he's
trustworthy cuz I said I was trustworthy
earlier all comes back I didn't think
that bad dialogue would come back not
mad at it it's good dialogue yeah it's
true what you said down there maybe you
were right but everything I've done I
don't think I could have done it without
you a they're in love now relativity
what do you mean Einstein's theory of
relativity grab hold of a hot pan a
second can seem like an hour put your
hands on a hot woman an hour can like a
second it's the best relativity I've
ever heard ladies Einstein explained it
that's why he's the master Oppenheimer
cut scene I would love if that's what
Einstein whispered to
him it's not about you at all Robert
Downey oh that's so good relativity we
got one there's two sharks left and
there's you in the dock doing a little
bathroom love they got pill for what's
wrong with these SCS now this feels sort
of like like alien but
underwater Oh
yeah
oh sounds like that spooky remix of uh I
got five on it oh
yeah a lot of people inspired by the
film Jordan Peele and James Cameron the
biggest movies of today can you imagine
deep blue sea oh yeah can you imagine
Jordan peele's shark movie oh man that'd
be great let's
go oh yeah
oh it's almost crer that they didn't eat
him I know and there's your Jurassic
Park uh oh yeah Dead Hand moment I
thought you were coming back for me one
of your stupid monitors BL P you want to
help me move it
here we do everything right together
right together D so close that
shot come on train that BGE totally know
what BGE is
[Music]
B the get that r a port out of the water
the most pained casual
expression apart no no and
electrocuted and he's not getting
electrocuted that's how water
works oh
ow oh is thewitch twitching the twitch
but they're going to leave him cuz he
respects them yeah like blue that's
right he's going to do the hand all the
sharks stop yeah Colin Trevor also big
deep blue sea F
yep
oh come on now punch him in the
nose whoa he helped they respect Thomas
Jane yeah I don't know why did he take a
shut and left like what just okay all
right a reason cuz Cinema ah I see there
wasn't a rule I missed Cinema
Dam
no oh pray together who Susan save this
man I'm done Brothers never make it out
of situations like this not
[Music]
ever oh no you got to get your research
I mean I do see where she's coming from
it would all die for nothing and you
know it's a fair conflict you know if
you could cure Alzheimer she risk yeah
it's true at this
point
oh even that came back not bad and it's
literally your treachery staring you in
the face right there oh that's a real
one I do like that they just played the
draws music almost like legally yeah
that oh it knew it brought the model
with
it no no no
no
and yeah God the physics of water so
comforting in one stretch and so
terrifying in another
yeah oh damn it damn
it oh you totally could have had
it I wonder if the people who get that
implanted would have shark memories
afterwards uh you know I was just about
to say like this movie has done precious
little like wet t-shir or anything like
that earlier and then it's like we're
going to save it for the third act yep
yep to save this for our most restrained
professional character but who also
she's doing it for science that's true
and Ripley did it so you know Ripley
could do it then he she's it's actually
the Ripley outfit almost
yes in the
face
sharked is she standing on that to
ground her like what's the I don't I
guess so why'd she strip I guess yeah it
must be rubber or whatever that material
is must be resistant or a base ground
it's ground yeah now you can get your
science I think it's still be alive no
they're going to eat that for the next
week L's still alive to cook yeah oh but
yeah okay all your floppy discs and your
brain juice are
gone did you do it
look I hate to interrupt this moment of
merging intimacy but can we get the out
of
here yes
please is this the only way exra hope
sinking swear no way at all I got to
utilize pressure before we blow the
airlock I got to let the room fill up
with water that's only going to take a
few seconds you
ready
oh yeah and I staff comfor all the days
of my life because I carry a big stick
days of my
life
come
amen they're the perfect Trio too the
man of Faith the man of Nature and the
woman of
science Holy Trinity of sharks
yeah
oh
it's a good subversion I think too that
Sam Jackson went the way he did like it
does tell you the movie and the Sharks
by extension mean
business
oh and then they all drown I would be so
dead wow what a
[Music]
shot that's good though create the VIS
ual
chaos come
on get out of the water no no we got so
close damn it I was afraid they would do
this I was afraid they would do this to
us you redeemed yourself too soon with
the
prayer
whoa punch it in the nose it's so the
surface death like oh is he going to
stab me stab in the eye stab it in the
eye take it out you can be a double
ampute you can live on take it out
LLS that was not LL Cool J nope that's
okay stunt man Cool
[Music]
J
my
oh no loss of life Cool J today yeah
live live Cool J yes Long
Live
oh oh please so much blood let them live
Christ get him to the short thank you if
he doesn't live they should all die it's
got to be yeah a big cautionary
helicopter rise up shot of like no
survivors or you keep LL alive those
fences are titanium underneath but on
top they're just plain steel they've
been hurting us using us to flood the
facility H that's the answer to the
riddle they hate because that's what an
8,000 PB thinks about about
Freedom about the deep blue sea he said
the
title we have to kill her that's the
first real smart thing you said all
day but you're one of them Thomas Jane
we ought to get about two and a half
sticks of dynamite out of these
players I mean I'm surprised there's any
left yeah take this into of this cable
hook it up to the positive side of the
boat battery and
boom
this would make an excellent Universal
Studio stunt show it really like does
look like they just shot it there and
removed the
backdrops damn I can't get
her I know how to get her you're going
to have to swim to
her bait yeah we watch the movie Bait
and then it'll get like Enchanted by the
story we can take inspiration from from
fellow shark
films
[Music]
ooh oh
my oh golly did you hit an artery that
must hurt too cuz it's like unless it's
fresh water out here where are we
um oh
yeah is that BL is that is that blood
coning blood thick thick I could go for
a snack I would like kro corn syrup
thank you yes
no the stun show set has failed
you you know I've had enough today I'm
pretty
full oh you do shoot it without your
Harpoon
ah science
[Music]
lady raise the
roof oh he knows he's one of them
he practically did just to the hand
thing
yes go King
arm yes L save you let's go oh yes let's
go shark's about to get
headsprung hey Mama said knock him
out shoot it please shoot it oh
oh oh nice no what it shot through Tom
Jane I think oh no he stuck it is stuck
him you have to come
on go Thomas day
go
oh we stuck in the fence oh
damn look at that rainbow in there too
oh oh my oh wow a big boy welcome to the
Chum Bucket woo I went to
[Music]
college man I want to know how they made
that like big old underwater explody
plume before he got swept away 45t shark
you hit
me you could have been worse I could
have let him eat your ass yeah 45 foot
shark 45 foot shark oh that song you
know hey party boat here comes the next
shift we saw that big exploding Red
Wave wow take me back to the ghetto
oh oh my God am man he
man oh it's renie Harlen this is the
song sharks wrote this one wrote the
story one wrote that monolog one wrote
the dialogue yes AA
goldsman
wow bleeding to death with no arms short
sleeves oh my
God this is
legitimately the rap theme to Deep Blue
Sea this is so good he's Will Smith in
it right now he really is he's
he's I he must have been inspired by
like wild wild west what was that era
minam black yeah was this 99 or 90
something oh man shark action supervisor
there were sharks you got to have a
shark action supervisor
deepest bluest my head is like a shark
spit what does that mean that it's the
chorus it's repeated what is it mean it
means he's tall enough that whenever he
goes places you can see the top of his
head over any like bookshelves or any
High surfaces
yeah deep as
blue I'm just so happy right this is
this is literally the last thing I would
have
expected you're getting up in a trailer
in 2000 something and this is just in
the speakers you don't know how good
life is guys listen if you're listening
right now on Apple and Spotify leave
five stars and don't click off this this
podcast just yet but because I want to
know your favorite music tie in to a
movie as done by an actor in it oh my
God that is a a very small list very
broad playing field koi I uh I'm curious
what your favorite is oh my is there a
cat in the
beat
maybe God
this song I'm sorry usually we just
start talking right away with I'm so
mesmerized by this leave that five stars
and then once you are done with this
podcast go spin LL Cool J's shark fin
song like five or six times just to
treat
yourself Coy that's a fresh drip you got
there it's it's bright and red it would
do well in this film to lure sharks and
that would be what I'd be do you could
dance your PE as a member of reject
Nation I'd be like sharks sharks
actually L drawn to motion and bright
colors oh join me sharks yeah uh you too
can get one of these or one of these oh
this is after you've been bitten by the
shark that's true that's true turn
purple well and the what's it called
what did he say when his the bruising
was was uh he was trying to keep it down
so totally totally we're all in spirit
of the film and you can be too if you go
to reation shop.com we got so many great
shirt just go
some of shirts there will be someday
we'll find a reason to do a shark te
there's a cat or something in this beat
yeah maybe sharks make that sound maybe
what does sharks sound like yeah what do
sharks sound you know yeah they capture
whale song and you got the dolphin you
know like which is they talk probably in
the sequel is there a deep blue c to bra
kep
growing could they call it deeper bler
deeper Bluer
man what a movie that was a blast and I
mean yes this movie obviously has like
its
own you know like I've never heard any
like really detailed description of this
because it's a very straightforward
movie for what it's doing Jurassic Park
of sharks but yeah Jurassic shark
Jurassic sh Co but is that megal is that
the Meg that is
Megalodon Jason Statham's in that one
yeah Jurassic they should have
called a Jurassic shark I know those
fools those fools you can't copyright
the name Jurassic because it's a time
period you could make a Jurassic shark
it is Asylum why haven't you made
Jurassic shark oh hey don't don't get
don't give that many as um if you do
that we're going to time stamp this aing
and you I just want to cut you go write
it I just want some concept cut Jurassic
shark you can send us $50 out of your
$500 yeah I think that's fair we've
given you that much ah I mean yeah this
is it's funny that this should be a reny
harand movie I I haven't seen all of
reny harland's movies by any stretch but
I do understand the sort of like
interesting Mystique that like reny
harand can make some like high
production fun you know craziness on
screen uh and often times you I mean you
know he's been behind some some pretty
significant bombs that were expensive
and and you know has often uh in more
recent years but you know like taking on
stuff that like
clearly might not be like the first I
don't know I get this maybe he loves
every movie he makes but like I get the
sense that renie harand is a guy who
could be making different kinds of
movies if a couple of his other movies
went to different directions uh what's
he known for uh he did well Cutthroat
Island was like a really big uh uh you
know high production semif flop and
whatnot but let's let's look him up
really quick so that I'm not misleading
you because he's done like a I think he
did Die Hard 2 um which you oh okay that
that's sounds right actually now that
you've said it
Die Hard Cliffhanger deep blue
sea Exorcist the beginning oh that's
what he's up to uh I think he did some
kind of big old action movie recently um
so yeah like it's funny I didn't know
who directed it but I'm like oh yeah
that's a totally unbrand that makes some
sense right music superviser LL Cool J I
love that his agent got him a music
supervisor title yes oh that's so good
and what does that mean then did he just
uh did he just his own song deepest
bluest sharks spin the name of the song
is called deepest bluest sharks spin I'm
so so many people wrote it it's on De
Jam okay Divine there's one that's not
an L Johnny Nash all right they're not
he did yeah he gathered other you know
but it's funny that he you know was able
to leverage that on top of the song you
know there are some needle drops there
are some needle drop he did the brick
layer uh he's he's done a oh he did Skip
Trace uh which is like an action thing
uh yeah some episodes of burn he's done
a bunch of the Covenant that like witch
I think die hard to is why I knew his
name yeah yeah and so like 99 the year
of the Matrix the year of Fight Club the
year of American Beauty American Pie the
six cents also brought us oh yeah deep
blue sea deepest blue as sharks fin yeah
this was saffron burough was her name I
forgot the actress's name she was like
in that late 90s early 2000s little
Heyday saffron burough is the richest
sounding name I've ever heard that is
some old money right there first name is
a spice your last name is like a verb
like burrow saon Burrows and not just
any spice but like a spice that fancy
ass you use sparingly and and is costly
yeah no she sounds like Saffron Burrow
yeah I've also never seen this oh
goodness well hey the Hof I've have not
seen uh I feel like they showed us like
clips from it in high school science of
it but but yeah not not like the actual
complete movie let's not watch it so
close to 2020 I feel like we just lived
out
so yeah with with my impression of renie
harand this makes perfect sense that he
would make this movie that was a fun
reaction though I'm actually really glad
it's usually uh there's a moment during
a a watch where I'm like either I didn't
need to see this or I wish I'd seen this
in the theater sure this should be seen
this way need to see this no no like
reacting to it was a better experience
than any other way I could have seen it
this is yeah like you what I mean like
this was a party perfect reaction movie
because it's like it it's always moving
at an enjoyable pace and for whatever
reason the blend of like yeah the the
script in terms of the characters is
often like kind of wacky and like an
action movie and it's like everyone's
making their water puns and stuff but
yeah like the actual nuts and bolts of
the movie it's like it doesn't have to
be this super deep rumination on
anything if it doesn't want to be as
long as it's blue as long as it's deep
and it's blue and it's at the sea
somewhere and and yeah it's like the
action you know punches and the suspense
is pretty good and like the things this
movie is here to do it's good at doing
and the cast yeah the cast you know
showed up so no matter how wacky some of
the dialogue can be like I still bought
everybody and I still liked the general
crew and I like that you didn't need too
much nonsense or melod drama really and
even initially when it was just LL on
his own I I was like oh damn like you
know think yeah it bumed he was on his
own separate movie and then he wouldn't
get to and then they made it a second he
joined the movie and it was like it was
great it was beautiful and and yeah and
you have you know Sam Jackson who always
even though this is earlier on you know
he's still well established by now and
brings a certain amount of weight uh to
a role like this that monologue was so
good was so good and then for him to get
I like I would have loved to be in a
theater during that moment because that
moment I think again I would imagine
that at the time this came out you
wouldn't have expected that because of
the casting of Samuel Jackson like is a
loaded thing again he's he's clearly you
know of the Sam Jackson you know status
that we know and it's only grown since
then so so that effect only gets better
if you don't know what's going to happen
because then it's like well it's Sam
Jackson he's got yeah he the rich guy at
the end that goes like I shouldn't have
done this I yeah exactly I thought he
was going to be Richard adaro I thought
he was gonna like close the Park and
this had that really had that like old
timey almost like Haze codes quality
where it's like okay like everyone
involved with this in the most sort of
morally dubious ways gets eaten or or
killed in some way shape or form and
it's like you expect that the main uh
you know uh doctor lady who's on the
poster is going to survive till the end
and she almost does but then like it
almost feels like that moral periphery
magic has to come back and be like no
this is you like abusing these sharks at
creating this situation and violating
all kinds of you know human laws as well
so like you you don't get to you know
triumph which is funny to me because and
there's no like canned romance between
her and Thomas Jane they didn't have to
Jurassic world us into having them you
know somehow come around to a with
intimacy yeah yeah yeah and it's like I
I bought the Ensemble of them in the way
you would like an alien like it's just
enough of that like alien movie thing
where it's like okay you've got an
ensemble in some remote lab and then
it's jaws and then it's Jurassic Park
should we have done this is this you
know a crime against nature and it's
like the be movie version of all that
stuff but like it's yeah well effective
and it gets the right things I think
pretty right that's why Asylum hasn't
done this yet cuz it's close like like
this is asylum's Jurassic Park it is
Jurassic shark it totally is I I had a
lot of more fun than I expected I I
hadn't known much I knew the theme song
cuz it's iconic but uh that's all I knew
and then when the cast kept popping up I
kept thinking like oh this is a bigger
movie than I thought it was I kept
thinking this was a smaller film but the
cast kept stacking and even though scars
guard wasn't big at the time it's still
LL was huge at the time uh I think
saffron burough was probably like the
height of her powers Thomas Jane was
like right around the Mist ERA this was
like the Ascension of of Thomas Jane so
this was like a stacked cast um and I
love SWAT and SWAT has LL and Samuel
Jackson in it so that's also around this
era um so I was really that's all I kind
of knew was was the song so I knew L was
in it but I I I had so much fun
discovering the fun of it and I think
the best thing this movie does is it's
one of the best ticking clock SL
Dynamite lit movies I've ever seen like
the adventure is constantly level up
level up level up the water is the
villain the sharks are the villain Man
versus self there's so much going on but
the tension is palpable and it really
makes you feel like you're in it like I
got cold at points I felt like I was
like in claustrophobia so like the
script is rough but the story is good
for what the movie is like the the story
allows you to keep ramping up that
tension and then when they needed a good
writing they gave him a monologue but
like it was uh I had a blast like and
I'm glad to watch it this way I think
this format like sharing it and yelling
was way more fun than like catching it
on TV even yeah it's hollyw it's like
Hollywood Pulpit its finest because yeah
like it it it I'm fascinated by movies
like this it's funny that it's nothing
like Silent Hill but the most recent
time I watched that movie I had this
fascinating experience with it where I
was like this is beautifully a midnight
movie you know for reasons that could
you know like there are things that
could be better about this that make it
kind of fun and cheesy but also like the
other half of what it's doing is
actually like pretty good at doing and
is really effective at and so it's like
it's one of those movies that has that
memik quality that has that sort of be
movie exploitation quality but without
feeling like anybody like it's like even
though the script is kind of wacky and
the dialogue is kind of wacky I don't
feel like anybody just didn't care you
know like I feel like you know people
had fun or at least like wanted to you
know make something Punchy and and you
know easily consumable um but yeah it's
like it had just the right amount of
like turn in the screws and yeah it's
like you get a guy like Ry harand who is
a bit of a vet who can you know take
that and Elevate like you said all those
ticking clocks and all those proximal
things of of yeah it's like this part's
collapsing and there's fire above us and
there's water down here and it feels
like you're watching some kind of
classic Disaster Movie like it's it's a
bunch of stuff all rolled into this yeah
like fun Blockbuster monster Movie
package and it's like it's one of those
movies where like any of the flaws
almost improve enhance it it's really
got its own like well that made it
better this is a movie full of bugs that
are
features in the best way man they did in
fact die hard now that I know the
director that really does allow for that
ticking clock to feel like yeah that
that was so that part is so impressive
yeah and all we needed was a naked
workout scene I mean we were close right
there next time that's in deeper Bluer
Seer yes uh this was fun we hope that
you enjoyed our Zeal because I was way
more cheery loud excited than I expected
that I had a lot of fun with that I'm
now going to crank that on the way home
along with headsprung which I love I
love going back to C but I'm a c person
and that song is actually about LL
hating C for listen to lyrics uh cuz
it's I'm not going back to C doesn't
like C he was the west coast East Coast
beef so at the time he was not in the
west coast side he was a New York guy
there's a lot of history about that song
but uh I do I do like headsprung because
it is when LL has come back to hipop and
I did like that he had that beautiful
Arc as an actor still acting but hrung
felt like he was like by the way I can
do it both so that was the era of LL I
like but uh Rock The Bells is one of
Eminem's favorite albums and Eminem
considers LL the greatest of all time so
I want to end this video by saying
listen to some LL put some respect on
his name he's one of goats doesn't get
appreciation I'd say him and Buster
rymes all you kids don't love to the
scale you should a lot of people know
the classics those are like right after
the classics right before the modern
they fell somewhere off the goat list
and that's wrong Buster rhes and Ella
Cool J icons and they're both in the
Halloween franchise I've never seen the
one with Busta oh it's
fun I will say this there are two very
prominent appearances by notable rap
artists in the Halloween franchise and
one highlight one is a good performance
and the other one is a highlight I mean
they're both
highlights one of them is actually like
a decent solid performance and the other
one is it Buster Rhymes cuz I'm worried
it's not it's definitely Buster rymes
great rapper Buster Rhymes oh I'm so
excited for you to see excellent rap hen
Resurrection is Peak is it in
Resurrection it's in Resurrection who's
in H2O LL is in H2O he's like
I was like and he's like an actual
performance it's good cuz it's Jo cor
one yay or Josh hartnet H2O I saw in
theaters so I was like I was way too
young snuck into that jigle might be in
it but I know I know haret is like jam
Lee's kid who's in the boarding school
which is like the faculty era Harnet
which is a favorite heartnet era of mine
and bu rymes they just they just put the
camera on him and they were like see the
thing is to to close us out to make the
deep blue sea review about Halloween rap
for appearances yes please L Cool J is
like an actual character and they're
like okay cool we're working with you
obviously you have your appeal but
you're going to be the security guard
and and you're going to be a character
then you watch resurrection and it's
like we we got Buster Ryan what do we do
camera on him and just let him do his
thing just let him do whatever he wants
and and that's the budget right there
you know who was good at Daredevil uh
have you seen the Coolio cut the
director's cut yes Kio so good that
speaking of rappers that can actually
Act coio is good and Daredevil yes
Justice for the Coolio the next koi
comic is actually just going to be a
rappers turned actors that are good yes
D Buster at the top of BU Rhymes right
up there Buster Rhymes you're a great
rapper uh well that's going to do it for
this episode of John and Coy discuss rap
unexpectedly at the end of Deep Blue Sea
please let us know in the comments below
who your favorite Raptor turned actor is
and who your favorite actor turned
rapper is because that's another
conversation uh also I haven't seen
twister since VHS and I the new Twisters
coming out this year that'd be a fun
rewatch uh cuz I haven't seen that I I
think it would almost count as a first-
Time watch cuz that was like
97 Kyer I would have been nine um so
yeah let us know below what you want us
to watch uh this is always fun teaming
up with John this one was a roller
coaster ride oh yeah with sharks uh much
love reject Nation we'll see you
soon shark shark shark shark shark shark
shark shark shark shark shark shark
shark